[Music]
pft on yahoo sports peter king mike
floria are some of the biggest stories
in the nfl and one of the best teams in
the nfl the kansas city chiefs finding a
running game committing to that running
game in very non-andy reed fashion
monday night against the buffalo bills
clyde edward zlaire had the big game
patrick holmes chipped in and i got
le'veon bell coming on board too peter
was this just a match-up driven outcome
for the chiefs where they recognize how
bad the bill's defense is especially
against the run or is this a sign of
things to come for the kansas city
offense
i don't think it's a sign of things to
come i think it's andy reid saying
these are horrendous horrific conditions
to play in it's like we're playing in
northern norway in december it was
ridiculous
and so you know you look at the
environment that you're in and you say
if we can push around the buffalo bills
we're gonna push him around we're gonna
get back on the plane without straining
uh mahomes's arm or
uh tyreek hill's uh feet whatever he's
got doesn't it seem like twice a game
tyreek hill comes up limping i mean you
want to save him for
games you're gonna have to win
uh and who knows suddenly there's a bit
of a competitive team in denver with
some defensive players we never heard of
like malik reed who might be hard to
beat but let's get back to that running
game just for one second
i think andy reid has tried to build
teams over the years
where
when he has to do either he can and in
this game in buffalo
he said why should we go away from the
run when every time i hand it to clyde
edwards hilary's gain in seven yards why
do that and by the way
did clyde edwards hillaire looked like
he woke up monday morning in the hotel
in buffalo looked in the mirror and said
i'll show them i'll show le'veon bell
who should be still touching the ball 20
times a game even though he shows up
this is not not this is not 2017 le'veon
that's what it seems like clyde edwards
hilaire was saying on monday night with
that performance
excellent observation yeah nothing
like the looming arrival of le'veon bell
to get more out of the rookie who had
who had
leveled off
to say the least after that week one
performance he ends up having the best
game of his young career and le'veon
bell is coming to give him some rest so
they don't have to lean too hard on
edward zelaire same skill set different
body a lot larger and we'll see what he
has left in the tank you know they got
lesean mccoy last year and they weren't
happy with him by the end of the year he
was inactive for all the big games so if
le'veon bell doesn't really fit if he's
not getting it done if he doesn't live
up to the level they want we won't see
much le'veon bell it's all up to him but
he will play this coming weekend when
they play those denver broncos and you
know peter i like the fact that they've
learned to be patient for andy reid even
when he's had the team that could run
the ball when he needed to he still
didn't want to run the ball he would
stray away from it and patrick holmes
has had to learn to be patient and and
you know he explained after the game he
had some rpos where he just kept handing
the ball off and i'm sure he was
confident if i keep the ball and throw
it i'll be fine but to get him to buy
into it as well i think is part of it
because he's got to have that utmost
confidence that he can always find a way
to move the chains with his legs or his
arms so i think it was a great
development for a chiefs team that
needed to get resettled after losing to
the raiders and and now they are uh the
challenge for them always seems to be
though peter against the teams that
don't get their full focus can they be
as dialed in as they were last night
against the bills and three weeks ago
against the ravens
i started thinking when i saw them trade
for le'veon bell
mike i started thinking back to opening
day 2017
when kareem hunt in his first nfl game
demolished the new england patriots
including on that one
uh pass play out of the backfield i
think against dante hightower you know
the 70-something yard touchdown
and that is andy reid he wants the guys
in his backfield to be able to be
proficient
uh explosive receivers now i don't know
that i'd call le'veon bell's speed
explosive because it isn't
but i think he's a crafty runner and i
think he's a good add to that team right
now and as far as what
what the chiefs have left
i think this game in denver is going to
be a very interesting test for them
because denver built its team
to try to be like kansas city we'll see
if they can be
and we'll see you next time for pft on
yahoo sports he's peter king i'm mike
florio have a great day
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports